hi I'm mano marks I'm a developer
advocate on the Google Maps API team
with me today is Steve Gregg hi there
Steve is a Google developer expert Steve
tell us a little bit about the Google
developer expert program Google
developer experts are really experts the
Google have recognized as an expert in
certain product fields so for me it's
maps and we go to conferences we talk
events we build by sample codes and blog
posts about how to use different
products you can really say that we're
than go to euros for the different
products yeah so you've built an app
using the iOS SDK for Google Maps and
it's called a synoptic tell us a little
bit about it so synoptic a pulls down
data from the UK Met Office
after sorry I don't know so the Met
Office is a government body here in the
UK that deal with all things while
they're related so forecasts they build
models a for how what's happening in the
way there are nylons and they kept them
kept the data forms a forecast on TV and
data as developers okay great
so the app we have running here why
don't we go ahead and take a little bit
of a look at it so that people can see
what we're talking about so what am I
looking at right now this is the
precipitation a forecast for the UK for
the next few hours and as you see the
layers are animating across the map and
you have bands of rain are coming across
the UK and more yellow the more red the
actual color is on the overlay more rain
that's in that area right okay so this
kind of thing that you would see in
you know no TV broadcast at night or
something like that and telling you
about what's what's going on okay so how
how did you do this animation so when
the app starts when the views loaded it
pulls down in the latest forecasts and
the latest observations for the UK and
then lines up the end if their images as
an animation and then loops random on
the map and so you can see this really
nice a flow of data across a flow of
Energy's across the map okay and you're
using ground overlays and you're
basically just changing the PNG that the
ground overlay uses yeah that's right
basically go away and fetch up all the
all the layers of the old images and
animation and when that's preloaded then
just start the animation off and for
every a loop rent the timer it will
insert the ground overlay onto the map
and it gives us nice illusion of
animation cool so what are some of your
favorite your favorite or relates that
you've gone here so my might so there's
two really awesome overlays here and my
favorite is the the clothes in the rain
together and as we fetch the images so
it does take a moment to fetch the the
images but once it does it they're
cached yes is that going run you can see
that's actually pretty fast yeah so yeah
go away and fetch all the images so that
we don't have this broken cycle of
animation we got one a infinite loop of
the animation of the latest forecast so
you have here the cloud cover and the
rain a cover of the UK forecast for the
next few hours and you can barely see
the you yeah exactly yeah this is this
is natural for the UK we're always under
clothes
so we have this layer which is really
nice because every time you load this up
it will loads up
the forecast for the next 8 12 hours
mm-hm and my other favorite is these
observation layers and you have this
infrared observation and this is a
really nice overlay because it's
actually the MU geez
come from the sass the weather
satellites there are looking down on so
it's the unprocessed MPGs that you don't
really get to see on the weather reports
and as you see you have this kind of
inverted looks where you can see the
cloud cover coming across again you
can't really see the UK but eventually
when you run the court in different days
obviously it's live data so we're
covered in plates you'll see but you can
see the overlay of the UK and it's a
really good indicator of whether you've
actually put the ground overlay on the
map correctly well they're all lanes up
to the bend and boxes so this is an
interesting one if you take a look at
the rainfall one you can actually see
that underneath the animated overlays
you actually have a is it a custom map
or a tile overlays it's a tile overlay
that I've created myself it just allows
us to have this a when we're putting the
ground overlays of the actual
visualization on top of it it just
Morelos the data to saying and allows to
remove the labels for the places because
we don't really want to see the labels
and on the map right so just get them in
a nice clean background background there
yeah okay cool and again this is this is
an open source project right so it's up
on github here's the the link for that
and if you have any if you want to
explore the Google Maps SDK for iOS
here's the link for that and
specifically if you want to look at the
the ground overlay documentation you can
look here alright well thanks for coming
in see no problem files we're having the
pleasure and thanks for listening